kein öl mehr aus russland so wollte es
die beschließen als harte sanktionen
doch man konnte sich nur auf ein teil
embargo einigen nur die einfuhr über den
seeweg wird verboten das in zwei drittel
der gesamtmenge des ölimporten ungarn
stellte sich beim sechsten
sanktionspaket quer denn das land ist
stark abhängig vom russischen öl und
wird nun weiter über die pipeline berufs
spar das heißt freundschaft versorgt
öl-embargo leid was taugt der kompromiss
unser thema heute in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
deshalb ist es wichtig dass auch dieser
gipfel erneut ein großes starkes zeichen
der geschlossenheit gezeigt hat dass wir
gemeinsam unsere schritte zur
unterstützung der ukraine beschlossen
haben und dass wir auch gemeinsam das
tun was notwendig ist um den russischen
agieren entgegenzutreten der
bundeskanzler heute auf der
pressekonferenz nach dem eu gipfel
betont die geschlossenheit herzlich
willkommen aus berlin ja wie einig ist
denn die eu wirklich darüber reden wir
jetzt mit diesen gesten ganz herzlich
willkommen christian petry er ist
europapolitischer sprecher der spd
bundestagsfraktion
ich begrüße profactor dann jeder
schwarzer politikwissenschaftlerin und
direktoren europa und eurasien bei der
open society von christoph von marschall
ist bei uns diplomatischer korrespondent
der chefredaktion des tagesspiegels und
zugeschaltet ist sonst boris kalnoky ist
ungarischer publizist und er leitet die
medienschule matthias corvinus kollegium
und die wird von unterstützern der
regierungspartei fidesz finanziert herr
forscher jetzt haben wir das heute
gehört dass die eu eben sich auf ein
teil embargo geeinigt hat nur eben nicht
das volle öl-embargo wasser was man ja
so lange wollte wie gut ist dass dieser
kompromiss das ist sozusagen das was man
die eu im moment erreichen kann und wir
müssen glaube ich sehr realistisch sein
die lage beschreiben das hat sich dieses
narrativ herausgebildet es ja im prinzip
nur ungarn gewesen ja die haben am
frechsten und am hartnäckigsten
sozusagen da verhandelt und auch
forderungen erhoben und auch die ganze
rhetorik des ministerpräsidenten war
mich sehr erfreulich aber es ist eben
nicht nur ungarn und wir deutschen sind
ja auch nicht scharf darauf dass das
pipeline öl nach schwedt auf einmal weg
ist jetzt zwar im prinzip politisch
bereit aber jetzt gar nicht sondern man
hat versprochen dass man gemeinsam mit
polen bis jahresende man überlegt dass
man darauf verzichtet also es ist nicht
so dass da alle anderen gegen ungarn
standen mit einer klaren
entschlossenheit wenn es so wäre dann
hätte ich einen vorschlag gehabt wie man
es macht dann muss man nicht so viel
wert auf die geschlossenheit legen
sondern hätte man eben gesagt eu - 1
dann sollen alle eu länder außer ungarn
bitte schließen dann hat man eine klare
beschlusslage ungarn steht dann selbst
auch öffentlicher pranger die eu hat was
beschlossen aber die lage war eben nicht
so einfach und deswegen ist glaube ich
das was jetzt beschlossen worden ist
gefällt uns nicht ist nicht optimal aber
es ist das was im moment heraus zu holen
war auch unter dem gesichtspunkt dass
die eu sich mit sanktionen nicht mehr
selber schaden soll als die ungarn
schadet petri wie würden sie den
bewährten der bundeskanzler sprach ja so
von geschlossenheit der hat das ja sehr
positiv eben auf dieser pressekonferenz
neben einem ausschnitt gezeigt haben
gesehen sehen sie es ähnlich positiv ich
sehe es eher nicht positiv weil es ist
sehr viel erreicht wurden glaube ich
zwei drittel ist nicht alles aber zwei
drittel sind zwei drittel des wird
wirkung zeigen ab januar ab januar
ich halte manche argumentation und sag
ich mal stellungnahmen jetzt unmittelbar
danach die ungarn stark kritisieren für
ein bisschen scheinheilig
ich bin dabei ungarn zu kritisieren
wegen medienrecht oder wegen behandlung
von minderheiten oder auch endlos aber
wenn wir deutsche sagen wir können auf
erdgas nicht verzichten und dürfen da
überhaupt nichts machen
und sagen dann ungarn die abhängig sind
von erdöl ihr müsst aber machen ihr
müsst die einigkeit der europäischen
union darstellen dann ist das ein
bisschen sag ich mal schwierig also
insoweit glaube ich dass der kompromiss
der da gefunden wurde durchaus trägt das
er wirkung zeigen wird und dass er also
obwohl er nicht dass 100% ergebnis
liefert doch ein signal für ein starkes
europa ist
hessen signal sagen sie aber es ist ja
eben keine klare geschlossenheit
ja am ende schon der beschluss der
befasst wird wurde einstimmig gefasst
also insoweit ist das schon nur nicht
mit dem ergebnis dass sich der ein oder
andere gewünscht hätte da bin ich völlig
dabei also ein radikales embargo aller
energieträger sofort das wäre die
maximal forderung aber da wird man auch
selbst bei anderen ländern keine
mehrheit finden die bundesministerin hat
eben brennpunkt der ard gesagt man muss
aufpassen dass das ziel von putin die eu
zu spalten dass das nicht passiert und
sie war sehr kritischen hat gesagt ich
verstehe das ganz und gar nicht die
haltung von umgang also ich habe es ja
aus der abhängigkeit situation und wenn
man es so argumentiert wie wir deutschen
für uns argumentieren dass wir uns nicht
selber stärker schaden wollen durch
sanktionen als wir russland schaden in
der linie wird ich sagen kann man das
nachvollziehen auch was ungarn macht
obwohl ich ansonsten liebend gerne dabei
britisch und herrn orban zu kritisieren
und auch scharf zu kritisieren hacker
nokia dann erklären sie uns doch einfach
noch mal warum wollte ungarn nicht einem
gesamten einem härteren öl-embargo
zustimmen
ja so zunächst fällt mir ein stein vom
herzen ich dachte ich ich müsste hier
alleine gegen alle an rennen um die
ungerechte position ein bisschen
verständlicher zu machen aber ich sehe
die logik erschließt sich eigentlich
allen es ist auch gar nicht so schwer
ungarn hat eine raffinerie diese
raffinerie kann nur russisches öl
verarbeiten das kommt über diese
pipeline die sie erwähnten
wenn ungarn morgen kein russisches filme
importiert dann gibt es in ungarn
übermorgen kein benzin mehr dieser
hindere umzurüsten dauert jahre das
kostet sehr viel geld gleichzeitig
müssten pipeline kapazitäten hinzu adria
erweitert werden
und das alles kostet wie gesagt zeit und
geld in der größenordnung von würde ich
sagen einer milliarde euro da muss man
erst mal das geld dafür haben und und
auch die garantie dass wenn wenn die
ukraine gibt man schließt oder russland
plötzlich kein öl mehr liefert das durch
diese pipeline das dass man auch anderes
anderswo kompatibles will kaufen kann
bis man dann eine neue infrastruktur hat
also russisches öl ja ok frau schwarzer
wie sehen sie ist ein weil das diese
regelung für ungarn ist jetzt ja nicht
die einzige ausnahme es gibt noch
bulgarien die dürfen weiter auf dem
seeweg öl aus russland beziehen und
griechenland und zypern dürfen dürfen
mit schiffen auch russisches öl
transportieren also hat die eu sich
dieses embargo an ich wirklich gut
überlegt
sicherlich und sehr lange verhandelt und
es zeigt sich eben daran wie stark die
energieabhängigkeit einzelner
europäischer staaten von russland ist
der bereich erdöl ist heute auf dem
tisch der bereich erdgas kommt später
und wir müssen dieser realität ins auge
sehen was man aber im falle ungarns sich
eben auch anschauen muss ist wie viktor
orban mit dem fall umgegangen ist er hat
die europäische union angegriffen die
kommission für diesen vorschlag in einer
ihm eigenen rhetorik und hat so brüssel
damit wieder verteufelt und wenn es
interessens ungarn an energielieferungen
gibt die sind völlig klar beschrieben
wurde neben aber ich glaube wir müssen
das im gesamtbild der ungarischen
russland politik sehen und wenn wir eben
noch mehr tun als nur auf öl und
mögliche gas-embargo es gucken und sehen
wer unterstützt die ukraine wie dann
sticht umgang schon dadurch heraus dass
es eben von ungarischer seite keine
militärhilfen für die ukraine bislang
gehabt ungarn hat viele flüchtlinge
aufgenommen das ist dem land hoch
anzurechnen aber ansonsten sieht man
eben hier klar die vermeidung einer
konfrontation haltung gegenüber russland
es gibt harte urteile ich habe eben für
annalena baerbock schon erwähnt die ganz
klar da sagt das war nicht in ordnung
wie umgang der agiert ist und der
bundeswirtschafts- und klimaminister hat
es ist auch sehr deutlich geworden heute
auf dem wirtschaftstag der cdu-nahen wir
da mal ein
die europäische kraft die die und
entschlossenheit europas hat sicherlich
gelitten durch das gewürge um das
sechste sanktionspaket und ich meine wir
sind alle ich auch als minister jeweils
der an zeit lautete kraft und wurde dem
deutschen volke zu widmen und das was
ähnliches werden die ungarn auch
geschworen haben andere länder auch
trotzdem gibt es eine verwechslung von
kurzfristiger kurzfristigen blick auf
sein eigenes land und langfristigen
einhalten von prinzipien die eigentlich
nur global verankert werden können und
mich irritiert und dass die höfliche
formulierung wie diese verwechslung
jetzt in diesem fall bei viktor orban so
tief eingreifen kann dass man ruchlos
einfach nur für seine eigenen interessen
pokert ruchlos für seine eigenen
interessen poker das sagt der
bundeswirtschaftsminister becker er kein
okay was sagen sie zu diesem vorwurf
jeder poker tour ist die interessen
seines landes die interessen des landes
sind die interessen der bürger dieses
landes wer das tut ist nicht hoch los
man kann jeder glaubt sie wissen ganz
plötzlich in der politik immer alle
programm es gibt da keine ausnahmen
ich respektiere herrn habe ich sehr sehr
erfreut überhaupt über die
gesamtleistung begrünen in der
bundesregierung dennoch diese worte sind
natürlich parteipolitik hier wird hier
werden innenpolitisch punkte
eingesammelt
trotzdem immer noch aber nein er ist ja
die frage ist aber auch was hat man
dafür bekommen dass er dann doch diesem
teil embargo zugestimmt hat
das wissen wir noch nicht im augenblick
hat er natürlich die ausnahme bekommen
also es geht ja auch gar nicht anders
aus ungarn muss dieses öl haben um
benzin zu produzieren für für das land
und für seine wirtschaft er hat ein
versprechen bekommen auch im notfall
wenn die pipeline abgeschnitten wird aus
anderen können russisches öl kaufen zu
können aber worum es
in der zukunft gehen wird irgendwann
wird man das thema wieder aufgreifen und
da geht es darum wie
finanzieren wir eigentlich die umrüstung
dieser dieser gesamten energie struktur
in ungarn und da
das ist nicht nur öl und nicht nur gas
es geht ja auch darum dass das die eu
gerne möchte dass ihr alle energie
sparen die die wirtschaft soll grüner
werden wir wollen mehr nachhaltige
energie all das kostet geld
dafür hat umgang sehr gute pläne
ausgearbeitet im rahmen der kopie
hilfsgelder die als maßgabe hatten das
alles grün werden soll die gelder
hierfür werden von der eu blockiert und
deswegen kann man das nicht
verwirklichen das wird also in einer
zweiten runde darum gehen wie viel man
von diesen geldern im grunde hinüber
schieben kann in einem neuen niveau und
dann wirklich die hilfen bekommt er
verwies wie würden sie es einschätzen
wann habe es so klar sagt da wird
gepokert und das so klar verurteilt
es ist natürlich so dass alle
regierungen ihre interessen verfolgen
aber es geht um das verhältnis zwischen
nationalem interesse und gemeinschafts
interesse und das ist nicht so dass das
überall dasselbe ist dieselbe abwägung
die eu steht vor der abwägung wie sie
mit ländern umgeht die immer stärker und
in einem missverhältnis ihre eigenen
nationalen interessen durchsetzen ohne
etwas für das gemeinschafts interesse zu
tun ohne das mitzutragen oder ist zu
einem geringen maße mitzutragen und
wegen der einstimmigkeit haben länder
die etwas erreichen wollen ja einen
unheimlichen hebel in der hand und mit
diesem problem muss ich die eu generell
beschäftigen ich hätte es jetzt für
falsch gehalten dass an diesem beispiel
durchzupauken aber wenn es nachher um
die korona hilfen geht und die frage wie
sich das zur rechtsstaatlichkeit verhält
da würde ich in der tat sagen da hat die
eu mittel in der hand die sollte sie
bitte auch nutzen es gibt im moment so
wie sich viktor orban verhält keinen
grund ungarn entgegenzukommen und
natürlich hat er den hebel in der hand
ein gemeinschafts entscheidungen was
auch immer er sich da aussucht zu
blockieren aber dann muss man eben
schauen in welchen fällen man das
anwendet dass ich vorhin vorgeschlagen
habe es gibt möglichkeiten bestimmte
entscheidungen - 1 zu treffen und das
muss man dann auch tun das nennt man
gaming and claiming im englischen und
dieses mittel muss man machen es ist
natürlich schwieriger geworden im krieg
nicht also aber irgendwas stimmt weil
die nazis an dem punkt nicht machen dann
könnte man ja sagen jetzt ist es doch
der punkt wo es
hakt im phagro es nicht machen weil
ungarn da nicht alleine steht das haben
wir ja in der eingangs runde schon
festgestellt dass es wäre sind und auch
die deutschen sind zwar bereit
inzwischen über die zeit ihr problem
schwelt anzugehen aber dann hat uns
gesagt dass sie erst morgen auch nicht
wenn sie aber verzichten auf das öl dann
was über diese pipeline kommend programm
und deutschland ja aber ab jahresende
nicht jetzt nicht wenn ich das richtig
mitbekommen habe ist zum jahresende
haben sich erst gar nicht und also
was ich nur noch kurz dazu sagen möchte
wir lernen dass sich in situationen die
krieg die prioritätenliste verschiebt
wir wären im frieden wäre die eu
wesentlich breiter konflikte mit polen
und ungarn einzugehen durch die
kriegssituation wächst der wert dessen
was man geschlossenheit nennt was auch
der kanzler nur es darf nicht zu einem
absoluten wert werden dass man gar
nichts mehr machen kann wenn man denen
die die geschlossenheit durchbrechen
wollen nicht mehr entgegenkommt das darf
nicht sagen die man glaubt wirklich da
draußen wirklich auf russland frau
schwarzer dass der blogger die aus mir
drin hat gesagt man muss eben sehen
jetzt mit der ganz dass das der westen
geschlossen bleibt bei putin auch auf
zeit spielt da hat sie völlig recht und
putin versucht ja seit jahren die
europäische union zu spalten durch
russische einflussnahme hybride
kriegsführung
cyberattacken desinformationen er ist ja
längst ein akteur innerhalb der
europäischen union und aus russischer
sicht wie aus chinesischer sicht gilt
für einstimmigkeit entscheidung in der
eu wenn man eine stimme gewinnen kann
über die einflussnahme dann kann man
entscheidungen die mit einstimmigkeit
gefällt werden verhindern und das sehen
wir im moment dass die nähe ungarn zu
russlands die russische wer die
ungarische position in allen
diskussionen über europäische antworten
auf diesen krieg natürlich beeinflusst
und jetzt bei dem sanktionspaket ist ein
kompromiss geschlossen worden aber das
thema bleibt auf dem tisch und deshalb
sehe ich die jetzige situation schon als
moment der wahrheit für die eu-27 wo
einzelne staaten deutschland gehört ja
auch dazu ihr verhältnis zu russland
grundlegend neu definieren das heißt
also über energie lieferbeziehungen die
frage in welcher art und weise man die
ukraine unterstützen möchte dann die
frage wie man mit moskau umgeht und wie
man über seine eigene verteidigung
nachdenkt dann wir in unserem land ja
eine ziemliche kehrtwende gesehen und in
ungarn steht die völlig aus die
beziehungen sind eng es gibt keine
wirkliche distanzierung und das ist das
was die europäische union weiter
beschäftigen herr kalnoky wie würden sie
denn das verhältnis russlands ungarns zu
russland beschreiben und wo sehen sie
denn gibt es langfristig eine strategie
sich unabhängiger zu machen von russland
ja also ich möchte frau schwarzer nicht
mehr treten und sofern gehe ich mal
davon aus dass sie in unkenntnis
schlicht und ohne böse absicht
viktor orban hat wiederholt öffentlich
und ganz klar gesagt seine russland
strategie seiner russlandpolitik ich war
nie davon ausgegangen dass putin die
ukraine am ende angreifen würde und und
muss daher komplett überdacht werden wer
genau hinsieht der der weiss genau merkt
genau das und dabei ist seine russland
strategie tief zu überdenken natürlich
muss der gesamte außenhandel neu
orientiert werden ist ja gar keine frage
der russische markt ist verloren auch
für ungarische unternehmen
dass hier eine änderung an steht ist
völlig klar wichtige ungarische
politiker haben wirklich sonnen klare
aufsätze auch auf englisch darüber
veröffentlicht man muss sie nur lesen um
zu verstehen was da los ist aber der
vorwurf dass ungarn mit seinem verhalten
die eu spaltet und damit putin sozusagen
in die hände spielt was sagen sie denn
dazu gehabt das ist auch das ist auch
uns in ungarn ist wahrscheinlich das
land das sich für sich am fairsten an
gemeinsame entscheidungen gehalten hat
bisher wenn es etwas mit trägern dann
wird es immer auch implementiert was man
dort
macht üblicherweise in ungarn ist die
sinnfrage zu stellen man stellt nicht
den gemeinschaftssinn über die logik
also nützlich da wird immer doch auch
die frage gestellt ist das eigentlich
vernünftig oder es ist einfach mal
wichtig dass irgendetwas alle zusammen
machen ist das wichtiger als dass wir
das richtig immer aber ist es nicht
immer meine kraft
entschuldigung aber ist nicht gerade das
geht ja darum sind es geht ja darum wie
man gegenüber putin auftritt und ist es
da nicht gerade das wichtig werde die eu
geschlossen ist nein das wichtigste ist
dass man die richtigen sachen macht und
dann kann man geschlossen sein warum
sage ich dass es hat schon zwei
sanktionen gegeben zu dieser sanktion
ist nie eine impact studie vorgelegt
wurden von der eu man hat einfach aufs
geratewohl
irgendwelche sachen beschlossen und
sieben jahre vergingen acht jahre
vergehen und russland wurde nur stärker
so stark dass das ist die ukraine
angreifen konnte auch jetzt so weit ich
weiß gibt es keine impact studie über
die folge alter sanktionen beschlossen
werden wenn ich mich irre dann was ich
nicht gerne verbessern ich bin ja kein
darf man auch dem gebiet aber ich halte
das dann doch drei monate nach
kriegsbeginn für für elementar dass man
versucht zu verstehen was man eigentlich
macht bevor man gemeinsam entscheidet
petri was würden sie sagen wie wichtig
ist die geschlossenheit der eu und wie
sehr wäre es sinnvoll dass man dann ja
in zukunft oder den nächsten monaten so
lange dieser krieg ja dann noch andauern
wird dass man vielleicht die strategie
geändert in der eu
also die basis aller beschlüsse ist der
vertrag von lissabon und der bietet
deutlich mehr möglichkeiten auch nicht
einstimmig beschlüsse zu fassen als dies
tatsächlich
praktiziert wird auch in diesem fall es
ist in der tat so wie eben gesagt wurde
das hat man sich nicht getraut wegen
auch wegen wegen der bedeutung dass man
die einstimmigkeit hier sieht in anderen
fragen ist die einstimmigkeit ein
hemmnis die konferenz zur zukunft
europas hat als ein ergebnis die
forderung dort eine reform anzusetzen
die einstimmigkeit oder die einheitliche
auf politik in der eu ist ein hohes gut
das dauert oft lange es wird oft lang
verhandelt das nervt auch manchmal ist
schwierig aber am ende hat sich dieses
prinzip durchgesetzt das sehe ich auch
jetzt so auch mit den beschlüssen die
jetzt aktuell gefasst werden man könnte
mehr fassen
um noch einen satz zu ungarn zu sagen
herr orban muss klar sich distanzieren
ich hab das eben gehört aus ungarn ich
bin selbst seit acht jahren
berichterstatter für ungarn im euro der
ausschuss das ist mir nicht so bekannt
also ich muss ehrlich sagen da gibt es
noch ein paar andere länder die nicht in
der eu sind wie sie haben zum beispiel
da muss man ein klares wort der
regierungschefs zur abgrenzung kommen
und wenn das nicht kommt steht man immer
im verdacht hier den spaltpilz auch mit
in die eu zu tragen den vorwurf muss
erobern und seine regierung sich machen
lassen würden sie das jetzt ganz konkret
seien bei dieser entscheidung hat
also die rhetorik ist dass es eben auch
genannt worden war um es höflich
auszudrücken weniger als glücklich im
ergebnis in der sache selbst habe ich
kann ich es nachvollziehen dass man
aufgrund der großen abhängigkeit nicht
sage ich mal sich selber mehr schadet
als man dem durch sanktionen russland
schaden will diese linie verfolgen viele
andere länder auch da ist ungarn in
einer linie drin das würde ich nicht
kritisieren aber die art und weise wie
man auftritt und die art und weise wie
man es darstellt spielt putin in die
hände dass er sich erfolgreich wehren
kann dass er ein vertreter hat der hier
den spaltpilz bringt und da muss viktor
orban sich tatsächlich an die eigene
nase greifen und verändern ich denke
auch dass es zwei dinge sind auf der
einen seite nationale interessen zu
vertreten und im bereich der
energiepolitik sehen wir dass bei vielen
regierungen und andererseits die
interessen eben öffentlich so zu
vertreten dass man neben ja die
europäische kommission für ihren
vorschlag prinzip angreift diffamiert
und da weit über die eigene
interessensvertretung hinausgeht
versucht damit die europäische antwort
auf russlands krieg in der ukraine zu
schwächen und deshalb kann ich die
kritik die heute von seiten der
bundesregierung kamen haben die
außenministerin gehört der
bundeswirtschafts- und klimaministerium
das sehr sehr klar formuliert wie groß
da auch die frustration ist das ein
regierungschefs chef sich eben
entscheidet so klar öffentlich zu
polarisieren und das schwächt natürlich
die europäische union und das ist sehr
sehr wichtig dass wenn es denn ein
umdenken viktor orban es gibt bei seiner
russland politik also handlung sehe ich
da noch nicht und nach drei monaten
denken wäre dann vielleicht der moment
wo man diese strategie genau ändern
könnte und sagen würde unser interesse
ist es auch dass die europäische union
mit ihren 27 staaten stark dasteht und
das interesse sehe ich aber in im moment
nicht aber dann schauen wir doch mal
darauf was hilft eigentlich denn alles
geht ja darum um den krieg zu beenden
oder in russland so zu strafen dass
russland geschwächt wird und eben auch
weniger geld hat um diesen krieg zu
führen der formate wie sinnvoll sind
denn diese sanktion wirklich und wenn
man sagt man will alles daran setzen
dass es hilft dann wäre es ja radikaler
wenn man sagt man guckt auf das gas und
da hat deutschland ja wieder ein
vergehen wie halbjahr hat mehrere
gebiete ich könnte jetzt auch über
frankreich und die nuklearindustrie
sprechen das ist ja ganz ganz großer tag
gefehlt das ist in deutschland nicht
debattiert wie in frankreich sowieso
nicht also die haben eine sehr hohe
abhängigkeit von gas die franzosen
setzten die energiepolitik auf nuklear
zivile nuklearkraft wo bekommt ja nicht
ihre brennstoffe wohin entsorgen sie
ihre brennstoffe warum diskutieren wir
nicht darüber welche abhängigkeiten da
die französische atomindustrie gegenüber
russland hat und wäre es da nicht
vielleicht auch an der zeit also ich
glaube ich wir können durch ihr können
im prinzip durch alle 27 länder gehen
und jeder hat da so seine
schwierigkeiten
bulgarien ist ja zum beispiel auch so
ein land das nicht nur besonders klare
antirussische politik mit vollzieht die
haben auch ein paar flüchtlinge
übernommen die haben auch mal waffen
über die grenze richtung gebracht aber
es ist nun wirklich kein land das an der
spitze der sanktions front steht nur die
machen daraus nicht in lautes theater
sondern die sind froh wenn bitte keiner
da so richtig mitbekommt und keiner sie
kritisiert und da bin ich wieder bei
dieser frage wer versucht sich
gemeinschafts dienlich zu verhalten und
das auch in der rhetorik zu
kommunizieren dann hat man mehr
verständnis wenn man sagt aber da müsste
bedarf und rücksicht nehmen das können
wir halt nicht mittragen und da würde
ich halt immer wieder sagen es gibt auch
maßnahmen die muss man nicht zu 27
beschließen dann sagt man eben wenn es
wichtige länder gibt die bereit sind ihr
ölimporte oder ihre gasimporte
signifikant zu reduzieren
dann sollen sie das bitte tun aber jetzt
nicht anders sagt man das wichtigste
oder eines der wichtigen signale
gegenüber russland ist die einigkeit des
westens dann ist das für mich immer klar
dass das finde ich eben es überbewertet
die geschlossenheit als prinzip das über
allem anderen steht wird überbewertet
auch mit geschlossenheit wichtig aber
wenn sozusagen diese prinzip der
geschlossenheit dazu führt dass man
eigentlich gar nichts mehr machen kann
weil irgendein aussteller muss man sagen
dann machen wir es eben zu 25 und ihr
zeigen auch noch mit dem finger auf
diejenigen die es nicht mittragen das
display ming und timing und das wird auf
die dauer erfolg haben gemeinschafts
interesse muss wieder stärker von einer
erkennbaren mehrheit unterfüttert werden
und die die das nicht mitmachen müssen
dann auch ein bisschen haben
öffentlichen pranger stehen herr petri
wenn man dem volk würde müsste man dann
sagen dann könnte doch deutschland als
so mächtiges land in der eu an ein paar
punkten auch wirklich anders noch voran
gehen und das ist ja genau das was der
bundeskanzler die ganze zeit vorgeworfen
wird er ist so zögerlich zu zaudernd wir
gebe es die möglichkeit wo sie sagen da
könnte deutschland dann mal vielleicht
vorangehen
also nur weil einer nicht am nächsten
tag in allen medien verkündet was er tut
ist er nicht so zögerlich und zaudernd
das ist ein kommunikations frage da bin
ich völlig dabei der eindruck kann von
außen entstehen von innen her gesehen
sehe ich das nicht so es ist in der tat
so wie man die frage dass das öl sieht
ob sage ich mal bis ende des jahres der
richtige zeitpunkt ist oder ob er für
möglich schwerer um ein deutlicheres
signal zu setzen damit darüber muss man
reden auch mit den kollegen in den
ostdeutschen ländern die davon eine
größere abhängig habe haben wie ich
jetzt zum beispiel kommen aus dem
saarland würde ich sagen noch ist nicht
so schlimm dass ich mich nicht aber das
werden so einfach also insoweit glaube
ich muss man das abwägen und der kanzler
tut dies auch und er kommuniziert dass
dies auch entsprechend in den
europäischen gremien und ich glaube da
hat er sich auch mit seiner auffassung
durchgesetzt also insoweit ist ein spiel
und auch gesagt es macht sinn wenn man
dinge besteht wohl nicht alle mitgehen
müssen genau dann gibst du dinge wo man
sagen könnte da könnte deutschland
vorangehen als ich jetzt zum beispiel
bei dem beschluss kann deutschland mit
vorangehen und ich bin im übrigen auch
der meinung wenn nicht alle am anfang
mit machen heißt das nicht dass sie auf
der strecke nicht mitmachen wenn ungarn
jetzt zum beispiel jetzt noch nicht
mitmachen kann oder bulgarien und es hat
schwer zu sagen und neben dem reinen
embargo und wir kaufen kein öl mehr auch
das konzept steht wir haben eine
alternative und bauen die auf dann muss
man dort die unterstützung auch seitens
der europäischen union insgesamt liefern
damit alternativen da sind auf der
strecke dann alle mitmachen können auch
das hat es in der vergangenheit in nicht
kriegszeiten anderen beschlüssen schon
gegeben dass man mit weniger als allen
angefangen hat und am ende dann doch
alle mitgemacht haben auch das ist eine
stärke der union aber dazu gehört mehr
als nur das reine embargo paket dazu
gehört ein gesamtkonzept herr kalnoky
was erwarten sie konkret von deutschland
und von erwarten sie dass deutschland
beim anderem bei einigen sachen dann ja
vielleicht doch eine stärkere
führungsrolle übernimmt weil das ist ja
das was viele kommentatoren sagen dass
der bundeskanzler besonders zu zögerlich
ist
eben wieder
bittet um verzeihung es ist ja es ist
eine koalitionsregierung die die ist
manchmal schwer hat ihre diversen
parteien auf einen nenner zu bringen und
deutschland ist zögerlich gewesen in
vielen aspekten seine russlandpolitik
einfach deswegen weil es eben eigene
wirtschaftliche und strategische
interessen hat eine führungsrolle ich
will es mal so sagen herr marshall hat
ja gesagt man muss nicht immer gemeinsam
entscheiden gemeinsamkeit kann ein
synonym für langsamkeit sein und der
betrieb auch sehr schön von einem
gesamtkonzept gesprochen ich würde noch
einen schritt weiter gehen jedes der
europäischen länder hätte vom ersten tag
an
unilateral einen barcoo verkünden können
für öl und gas aus russland und die
anderen unter zug sagen ihre zu
zersetzen können keiner hat's getan
dass das sagt vielleicht für sich schon
etwas aus deutschland wird einfach so
weitermachen wie er das derzeit wie
bisher ist jetzt seine interessen
abwägen und dementsprechend
wahrscheinlich eher langsam als
stürmisch
versuchen denn doch die richtigen dinge
zu können frau schwarzer was sehen sie
jetzt für die nächsten schritt bei viele
sagen es ist jetzt so ein einen
wendepunkt auch in diesem krieg wie was
wäre jetzt wichtig um diesen krieg zu
beenden oder einfach einen stillstand
war bei zu führen ich denke im moment
ist immer noch die militärische
unterstützung der ukraine
die große priorität
und das geschieht im moment aus
europäischen staaten das machen die
amerikaner jetzt haben wir gerade in den
letzten tagen wieder gehört was an
waffen geliefert wird das ist auch
wichtig dass die bundesregierung die
zugesagten waffen schickt denn im moment
müssen wir davon ausgehen dass russland
diesen krieg mit aller gewalt noch
weiter führen wird und dass es eben
weitergehen wird auch mit dem morden der
zivilbevölkerung mit der deportation von
menschen mit den verbrechen an der
menschlichkeit und deshalb ist das
interesse der ukraine legitim diese form
der militärischen unterstützung zu
bekommen denn die frage wie man russland
in der ukraine
zurückdrängen kann ist wirklich
essentiell für das land und es gibt eben
in den letzten wochen ja auch wieder
alle möglichen versuche mit wladimir
putin zu sprechen und
verhandlungen zu eröffnen aber man sieht
eben sehr klar er möchte nicht
verhandeln es gibt keine anzeichen dass
im moment ein interesse auf russischer
seite gibt auch nur einen
waffenstillstand für einige zeit
einzugehen und deshalb ist im moment die
militärische unterstützung plus die
wirtschaftliche sanktionierung über
energie hinaus es gab jetzt in dem
sechsten sanktionspaket auch noch
finanzielle sanktionen die die wichtig
sind um für russland diesen preis des
krieges auch zu erhöhen denn die ukraine
muss dabei unterstützt werden den krieg
so zu gewinnen dass sie ihr territorium
schützt und ihre staatsform schützt es
geht hier letztendlich um die frage ob
die demokratie und die territoriale
integrität souveränität und identität
der ukraine erhalten werden kann und für
die ukraine ist es ja auch wichtig also
zu einer art hoffnung zu haben oder ist
heißt es immer wenn die eu wenn die wenn
die ukraine in die eu kann sie hatten
antrag gestellt als beitrittskandidat
jetzt aufgenommen werden sollte das hat
ursula von der leyen ja gesagt sie
drängt darauf dass es beim nächsten
gipfel dann die ukraine offiziell zum
beitrittskandidaten erklärt wird ist wie
hilfreich ist dass ich halte das nicht
für besonders hilfreich weil das falsche
hoffnungen weckt probleme mit anderen
beitrittskandidaten die viel früher zum
kandidatenstatus erreicht haben führen
würde dass das halte ich nicht für für
eine sinnvolle angelegenheit muss ich
klar gesagt dass man ihnen sagt ihr habt
die perspektive und irgendwann und so
weiter aber das muss an klare
bedingungen geknüpft seien die ukraine
ist überhaupt nicht weder von ihrem
innenpolitischen zustand noch von
wirtschaftlichen noch von anderen in der
lage aber mir ist noch ein anderer punkt
wichtig den sie vor erwähnen in
deutschland gibt es immer wieder diese
ja aber wie können wir schnellen
waffenstillstand erreichen wie können
wir schnell zu einer verhandlungslösung
kommen das wird in sehr vielen
europäischen ländern mit höchstem
misstrauen betrachtet warum nicht weil
die nicht waffenstillstand wollen und
ich wollen dass das morden endet sondern
weil ein waffenstillstand zu einem
falschen zeitpunkt die ukraine in eine
sehr vorteilhafte lage versetzt das ist
verständlich so wie wir die jahre seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg die deutsche
gesellschaft verbracht haben aber aus
die entscheidung darüber zu welchem
zeitpunkt man über waffenruhe und auch
gebietsabtretungen oder nicht verhandelt
das entscheidet einzig und allein die
ukraine da sollten sich nicht frankreich
einmischen da sollte sich nicht
deutschland einmischen solange die
ukraine außen mitarbeiter kam nehmen
wird als mensch oder einer der von jetzt
ja mit putin also dass das kind jetzt
wir haben aber ja ich muss wirklich
sagen nein nein man muss die ukraine
fragen der bundeskanzler ist auch gesagt
solange die ukraine kämpfen möchte
werden wir sie unterstützen die bringen
die opfer das geht um ihre gebiete ich
meine was würde man sagen er nicht klar
die ukraine sollten also sollten wir
dann sagen wenn jemand von außen sagen
würde kommt opfert man das saarland
damit endlich frieden herrscht oder
frankreich so malt die bretagne aufgeben
das wird von außen gesagt kann man sich
vorstellen wie das auf franzosen wirken
würde also wenn die ukraine die
entscheidung fällen es lohnt sich für
uns nicht mehr noch viel mehr
menschenleben zu riskieren um 1
zerstörte stadt im don was
zurückzuerobern dann müssen wir sie
nicht vom gegenteil überzeugen aber
solange die ukrainische gesellschaft und
die gewählte ukrainische führung sagt
wir wollen weiter kämpfen dann haben sie
allen anspruch auf westliche
unterstützung und man muss vor allem
sagen wir entscheiden das doch gar nicht
ich meine das entscheiden doch wie die
die entscheidende militärische hilfe
leisten wie lange sie das tun was in die
usa das ist groß das sind osteuropäische
länder durch die das direkte geht nicht
die gehen ja auch ein risiko weil es
über die grenze geht also wir in
deutschland sollten nicht überschätzen
welchen einfluss wir überhaupt haben auf
die frage wann es verhandlungen gibt
wann es eine waffenruhe gibt und was da
möglicherweise besprochen wird ok also
finde ich interessant dass sie das so
dass sie das so gering schätzen und dann
ich hatte eigentlich ich möchte einfach
ein sehr realistisches verständnis in
der deutschen gesellschaft haben dass es
nicht darum unseren seelen frieden mit
uns wie verhalte ich mich zum krieg und
so weiter geht sondern es geht hier um
existenzielle interessen eines volkes
und eines landes und deshalb sollten sie
die unterstützung haben weil sie opfer
eines angriffskriegs wenn die sagen
jetzt wiederhole ich mich wir wollen
nicht werden dann ist das was anderes er
bete wie sehen sie das ich sehe da kein
widerspruch dass hamakom und herr scholz
mit allen telefonieren auch mit herrn
putin das sehe ich nicht im widerspruch
das selbstbestimmungsrecht der ukraine
sondern das ist eine sinnvolle ergänzung
und wenn das einvernehmlich auch mit den
ukrainischen verantwortlichen passiert
dann ist das eine gute sache und sollte
auch weiter praktiziert werden denn
neben dem golden des krieges dem tod und
dem leid ist es doch immer sinnvoll zu
versuchen noch ein gesprächsformat zu
finden um halt tatsächlich auch eine
friedliche lösung zu haben sie haben
eben das gewehr wort gebraucht dass das
möchte ich vielleicht doch nur
aufgreifen die ukraine soll nicht
gewinnen
ich habe mal dass ich euch gesagt oder
ostern soll ich gewinne der kanzler sagt
bisher nicht die ukraine soll diesen
krieg gewinnen und das ist auch gut so
und zwar deswegen wenn gewinnen
impliziert der ansatz ist nicht mehr da
wenn sie sagen russland gewinnt
impliziert dass die ukraine ist nicht
mehr da wenn sich sagen die ukraine
gewinnt dann ist russland nicht mehr da
oder dass putin die putin regierung
nicht mehr da das was kanzler stolz
gesagt habe was wir auch unterstützen
ist dass die integrität der der ukraine
die territorialen integrität der ukraine
gewahrt sein muss und dass die
russischen truppen dieses land verlassen
müssen das ist nicht gleichzusetzen mit
dem wort die müssen gewinnen gewinnen
würde weitergehen und das würde ich auch
nie so formulieren sondern ich so wie es
auch in der deutschen politik formuliert
wird wir tun alles dafür dass die
russischen truppen das land wieder
komplett verlassen und dass das was
völkerrechtlich gilt dann auch wieder in
der integrität der ukraine gilt das ist
das ziel von gewinnen in der form der
andere ist weg wohl nicht erlernt und
die hier die position russlands in
dieser zukunft wenn die ukraine
besteht sie machen jetzt direkt sagen
russland darf nicht dann weg sein dass
das würde das heißen also es wird es
wird den russischen es wird den
russischen staat geben
und ich würde mir wünschen dass es keine
regierung mehr gibt in dem ein herr
putin was zu sagen hat das würde ich mir
wünschen und da auch die kräfte in
russland zu unterstützen die zivilen
kräfte aber auch die politischen kräfte
die auch da demokratisch daran arbeiten
auch das würde ich für sehr gut halten
auch hier sage ich mal eine schritte zu
tun aber russland als staat als solches
das wird dann auch nach einem
friedensschluss weiter so existieren da
kann ich mir ein anderes aussagen dass
man also die muss man jetzt darüber
nachdenken welche positionen die ukraine
vielleicht als möglicher eu
beitrittskandidat hat und welche
position müsste denn dann russland haben
denn bis jetzt keine klar sagt russland
die ukraine soll den krieg gewinnen also
sagen einige dass die ukraine den krieg
gewinnen soll beispielsweise auch einige
vertreter der baltischen staaten und ich
denke nicht dass sie meinen dass damit
dann russland
liegt ausgelöscht sonst was sein soll
sondern es geht um einen angriffskrieg
russlands auf die ukraine der in der
ukraine ausgefochten wird und ich denke
dass das diejenigen unter den europäern
die fordern dass die ukraine diesen
krieg gewinnen soll meinen dass russland
sich zurückziehen soll dass es das
territorium verlassen soll und die
integrität der ukraine in diesem
angriffskrieg gewahrt bleibt und glaube
niemand von denjenigen die sagen dass
die ukraine den krieg gewinnen soll
meint dass die ukraine dann noch gleich
russland angreifen soll und in
irgendeiner form militärisch besiegen
soll das ist überhaupt nicht in der
diskussion und die die frage der der
integration der ukraine also der der
antrag ist gestellt und zwar auf
einladung der präsidentin der
europäischen kommission damit wurden
erwartungen geweckt denke jetzt wäre ein
signal dass die verhandlung eröffnet
werden ein sehr wichtiges politisches
für die ukraine aber gleichzeitig muss
ganz klar gesagt werden dass der
beitrittsprozess nicht verändert wird
für die ukraine das alles erfüllt werden
muss und damit dieser realismus auch an
den tag gelegt werden muss dass im
grunde der der kandidatenstatus nicht
eine beschleunigung des prozesses heißt
nicht ein erleichtertes
beitrittsverfahren das kann die
europäische union nicht machen das wäre
unfair all denjenigen gegenüber die
schon eine ganze weile verhandeln aber
ganz ehrlich diese serie ist denn dann
dass die ukraine
das ist realistisch dass sie das
irgendwann wird aber dazu muss es
zunächst einmal frieden und stabilität
in der ukraine geben das muss rein
abschluss der reformen die zu einer
gesunden demokratie dann in der
vollendung führen die ukraine ist
bereits eine funktionierende demokratie
und es fehlen aber noch einige reformen
die natürlich umgesetzt werden müssen
und was im moment so wichtig ist ist
dass die europäische union diesen diesen
blick den russland wirklich dem
kontinent aufzwingt nämlich unter dem
eindruck des krieges geopolitisch über
fragen der erweiterung nachzudenken und
zu fragen was bedeutet es denn wenn wir
die westbalkanstaaten nicht als
beitritts also als länder innerhalb der
eu haben was heißt das wenn die ukraine
nicht den schutz der eu den sehr will
hat das sind glaube ich die wichtigen
fragen und deshalb ist es so
entscheidend dass man eben jetzt wenn
man über die ukraine und den
kandidatenstatus spricht auch sehr
ehrlich mit den westbalkanstaaten umgeht
einerseits erwartung formuliert
andererseits aber auch endlich die
ausstehenden verhandlungen und
mazedonien und albanien die seit jahren
warten eröffnet wird der halle unter
strom um genau das loszutreten damit
dann auch dort das nötige getan wird
dass diese staaten die reife haben um
bei dem weitere zur eu zu vollziehen
würde ich gerne mal nach budapest die
frage geben herr kalnoky was halten sie
denn davon wie wie realistisch finden
sie es und wie was würde das bedeuten
für die eu wolle die ukraine
mit league würde und wo du jetzt erstmal
den dingen den beitrittskandidaten
status erhalten würde
wären sie erlauben möchte ich kurz
reflektierende über die fragen die sie
allen anderen besten gestellt haben im
bunde ist die frage aller europäischen
länder welches sind unsere kriegsziele
in diesem konflikt wir alle sind stille
teilnehmer an diesen krieg in dem wir
waffen liefern indem wir unterstützung
liefern indem wir sagen was geschehen
soll was nicht geschehen soll
und da gibt es zwei eine klare
trennlinie eigentlich zwischen
amerikanern und engländern die mehr oder
minder deutlich sagen wir wollen dass
dieser krieg weitergeht bis dahin so
klein ist dass es auf absehbare zeit
keine bedrohung der werden kann für den
westen und dann gibt es eine andere
gruppe von ländern dazu wird frankreich
dazu wird in deutschland sicher die
kanzlerpartei die spd dazu gehört auch
ungarn die eigentlich nur eine sichere
wahrheit erkennen können in der zukunft
nämlich irgendwann wird dieser krieg zu
ende sein und russland wird immer noch
da sein und es wird immer noch unser
nachbar sein wir werden immer noch mit
russland auskommen müssen
aber was heißt das dann wie welche art
ja auch nicht das muss die zukunft
zeigen aber aber aber man erkennt den
unterschied in der in der behutsamkeit
relativen behutsamkeit mit der die
franzosen aber auch olaf scholz und eben
auch um dann formulieren und die diese
radikale art und weise wie wie ausland
und amerika argumentiert wird und dann
jetzt nochmal com versteht die eu
mitgliedschaft
ja ich meine wenn wir wenn wir die
kopenhagen
kriterien ja wir können die entwicklung
über bord werfen und und die ukraine
aufnehmen da müssen wir auch aufhören
auf polen und ungarn rumzureiten
oder aber wir sagen ganz ehrlich das ist
das ist ein prozess der 30 jahre dauern
kann es gibt aber ein grundprinzip das
eigentlich immer gegolten hat auch für
die nato
wir sollten keine länder aufnehmen die
sich in einem in einem konflikt in einer
konfliktsituation betreffen mit einem
anderen mächtigen land das eigentlich
immer unsere unser grundprinzip in der
eu und den danach
also erst wenn der pianist ist also wir
müssen aufpassen an zwei dingen nicht
ein gut gemeintes und auch wichtiges
signal die gurke ukraine zu senden und
damit ein schlechtes signal an andere zu
senden also moldawien und georgien haben
auch probleme mit besetzten gebieten
durch russische truppen und haben
ausgleichen aus gleicher befürchtungen
auch das ansinnen also auch dort müssen
wir einen gleichklang hinbekommen und
wir haben mit albanien und mazedonien
beitrittskandidaten die warten seit
jahren auf ihre erste beitrittskonferenz
damit die kapitel eröffnet werden können
wir haben mit nico rückschritte bei den
kapiteln wir haben in boston eine
schwierige situation und serbien müsse
sich auch mal bekennt und wo es hin will
also es ist ein sehr fragiles element
und deswegen einen solitär nur nach
ungarn zu schauen muss man immer abwägen
mit allen anderen die damit man ein
richtig gutes paket macht und von daher
kann ich mir vorstellen die kopenhagener
kriterien gelten ein beitrittskandidaten
status ist ein erster schritt nun kann
man machen dann folgen die erste
beitrittskonferenz 35 kapitel bei
finnland hat es sechs jahre gedauert und
die türkei ist schon über 60 jahre kam
das ist die bandbreite über die wir
reden ja das ist dann vielleicht auch
noch über die türkei ganz am schluss
würde ich gerne mal ansehen machen die
frage stellen wir haben schöne gehört
von herrn scholz heute eigentlich so
sagte wie geschlossen dann doch die eu
war dann herberg der das ein bisschen
anders sieht die außenministerin hat
sich auch sehr kritisch geäußert also
wie sie stark ist die ampel koalition
hier in berlin wirklich da gemeinsam
unterwegs weiter sie ist in einer
gewissen bandbreite gemeinsam unterwegs
aber man hört eben dass die akzente
unterschiedlich gesetzt werden oder sind
akzente die hätten wir uns glaube ich
vor beginn dieser situation auch nicht
so vorgestellt also hätte ich geglaubt
dass die grünen mehr für
waffenlieferungen sind als die fdp oder
die spd nein hätte ich nicht gedacht
aber vielleicht ist es ja auch manchmal
die weisheit der geschichte stellen wir
uns mal vor wir hätten jetzt eine
schwarz gelbe bundesregierung was auf
den deutschen straßen los wäre mit anti
kriegs protesten da aber die grünen und
die spd in die regierung eingebunden
sind verfolgen sie selber die politik
die man aus regierungsverantwortung
trägt und das letzte was ich vorhin
sagte dass die ukraine im prinzip
erscheinen sollen das sagt der kanzler
auch das ist überhaupt kein dissens zum
kanzler der kanzler hat ja auch er hat
sogar in einem interview gesagt ist eine
bedingung für verhandlungen dass die
russen sich zurückgezogen habe aus den
besetzten gebieten da dachte ich der
geht aber weiter hat das inzwischen
nicht wiederholt aber jedenfalls dieses
prinzip am ende kriegt die ukraine
unterstützung so lange sie es will und
wir drängen sie nicht in verhandlungen
die sie noch nicht möchte das glaube ich
wird eigentlich auch von kanzler und der
regierung mitgetragen und bei den grünen
sicher auch sind wir gespannt ob das als
würden sich positiv sehen dass das was
die da zum zusammen das ist gut zusammen
funktioniert hätten ja das glaube ich
schon ich möchte ergänzen stellen sie
sich mal vor freude pin hätte die
frankreich wahl gewonnen über was wir
jetzt noch reden würden also das ist
ganz interessant wie einzelne nationale
entwicklung einen großen einfluss auf
das gesamtpaket europa haben können ok
vielen dank die diskussion vielen dank
herr kalnoky bruder fest herr petri da
war schon vor schwarzer vielen dank
ihnen für das interesse und fürs
zuschauen morgen sind wir natürlich
wieder für sie da dann fragen wir hohe
schulden explodierende preise was plant
die politik bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]